this mother-and-daughter hardly leave
each other's side there walked by the
sea and Liverpool is a daily ritual has
a big dog Pam maudsley has devoted her
life to looking after her daughter
Louise cheese and bread please and
Louise was born with deformities 42
years ago come on the doll her
development has been very restricted
that's an armful isn't this greg louise
has needed 24-hour care ever since her
birth Gus it'd be hot it's a full-time
job for Pam she recalls the difficult
days after the birth all I bones stop
growing and that stopped her brain from
growing so she's got a very small head
and and I brain stopped growing so it
couldn't develop anymore and when she
had an operation on her brain when she
was about 10 months 9 months old they
found there were great cavities with
nothing in Pam is certain that the cause
lies in a pregnancy test that she took I
went to my doctor to save us I was
pregnant and he gave me two tablets want
to be taken one day one the next and if
I didn't have a period I was pregnant
and I'm a dental epirus I was pregnant I
I just took what he gave me didn't give
me a prescription he got them from a
drawer in his desk this was at a time
when the drug had already long been
suspected of damaging the embryo duo
genome which is called premadasa in
Britain was made by the German
pharmaceuticals firm sharing which now
belongs to buyer authorities had warned
about the drug two years before Louise's
birth but it was only taken off the
market in the 1980s Louise could have
grown up like her relative woody
you do a little bow if her mother had
not taken the pills Pam is often plagued
by feelings of guilt and she is
determined to find out what really is
responsible for Louise's disabilities
the cemetery rolled has joined an
association that looks into birth
defects caused by medication they've
brought the promoters case to Parliament
we have the second inquiry meeting on
Friday the fourth of December there are
thousands of cases not all the children
suffered such severe deformities as
Louise some have less serious birth
defects heart problems are a frequent
problem now my hope is that the inquiry
will be able to uncover and assess all
the information that we've sent we have
sent over 40 studies to be assessed by
the panel from the british parliament
has opened a new inquiry hope is that
the pharmaceuticals company will put all
the facts on the table cheering actually
did discontinue the product and they
stopped using it for the pregnancy test
which again surely must suggest but
there is something wrong with these
rather who I will be taking off the the
market most of the families affected
simply want to know where the guilt lies
what's responsible for the birth defects
but some want more than that an apology
is not good enough I want to know for
the rest of my life I will I will be
okay financially if I have to give up
work I know that I should be able to
still be able to have a good quality of
life you know i am lucky i keep saying
about lucky these people in wheelchairs
but i don't know what the long-term
effects are going to be yes yes so far
the pharma company has been able to
resist complaints from all over the
world according to German law the
plaintiffs would have to prove to
sharing that the drug caused the defects
this is almost impossible can you got
two fingers in there Oh give me strength
Pam maudsley hopes that politics will
prevail over the justice system and that
something will finally happen after more
than 40 years it'll just give me peace
of mind all this time 42 years I just
want to know what caused lose-lose
problems I just needed to know cuz I
used to think you know when she was
first born is it my fault what have I
done did I do something wrong in the
pregnancy from the point of view of the
pharmaceuticals giant nothing is proven
Pam and Louise are prepared to fight but
they know they won't be able to win this
battle without help